what is asset protection it's simple
it's protecting what's yours what do you
see with what I'll call your average
kind of Citizen right what are they
doing when it comes to asset protection
historically the number one investment
from an asset protection perspective is
gold why gold pretty much always holds
its value is there anything specifically
at the intersection of crypto and
whether it's estate planning tax
planning anything like that well yeah I
I've seen a lot of elements in the last
particularly two or three years one of
the things that people love hearing are
wild Tax Strategies what's the craziest
thing you've seen someone do from a tax
mitigation standpoint all right guys
bang bang I'm here with Joel uh very
excited about this conversation I
thought a great place to start would
just be asset protection is a concept
many people have heard about they think
that only super wealthy people do it but
they have no clue why so many people are
focused on asset protection you spend
all day for years and years and years
thinking about this talking to clients
what is asset protection and why is it
so important for people to consider
well great and again thanks for having
me on the show it's a topic near and
dear to my heart I uh grew up with a
family where my father died when I was
just a baby and uh I saw my mom you know
a single mom trying to raise small
children uh go through a lot of
difficult times and be taken advantage
of and it really kind of impressed upon
me uh this notion at an early age about
trying to protect your wealth preserve
it pass it on and everything that I've
really done in my 32-year legal career
has been with that in mind and quite
honestly we have very wealthy clients
but I also have you know School teachers
and secretaries and uh they would
certainly tell you that you know
protecting their wealth is equally if
not more important to them because they
really don't have the ability to go and
earn it back so when I'm talking to a
school teacher 60 years old and they
have a nest egg of a half a million
dollars they come to me and say you know
what are the best ways to protect my
wealth I I take it very personal very
seriously and I try to come up with
techniques to help them we we issued a
position paper many years ago and I
updated all the time about uh different
concepts based on your wealth obviously
you're not going to you know set up a
family office for example if if your net
worth is five hundred thousand dollars
so we want to make sure the solutions
that we come up with are consistent with
uh the the needs and the net worth so
when you when you ask that question you
know what is asset protection asset
protection is it's simple it's it's
protecting what's yours
um you know you're not worried about
necessarily growing your the pie
although you know if you have it
protected well and insulated from taxes
and things like that it will grow a lot
of clients tell me that that you know
know if you want to think of it as a
sports analogy we are the defense right
you have investment advisors and people
like that telling you about offense
they're telling you what to invest in
I'm sure you have a lot of people on
your show they're talking about crypto
or gold or whatever whatever the the
offenses were the defense we're
basically saying we want to help create
the right structures and strategies to
protect what's yours so you can sleep at
night and know that no matter what
happens nobody can ever take what you've
worked hard to to earn or what you've
inherited or you know how your business
has grown and become very successful and
you've achieved something we want to
help you protect what you already have
so so that really is asset protection
generically protect what's yours so when
you think about this you've said
previously this idea of protecting the
asset preserving it and then passing it
on to the next Generation I almost think
of those as like kind of three different
buckets explain a little bit the
protecting and preserving component
before we get to passing on so
protecting and preserving what exactly
does that usually entail
yeah so you know protecting assets can
be done a lot of different ways uh
normally when clients come to see me it
will end up involving different types of
legal structures so the you know the
main structure that people use to
protect wealth is a trust structure now
trusts have been around for over a
thousand years uh actually there are
elements of of trust law that go back to
Roman times if you go back to you know
uh the early BC times for example only a
Roman male could inherit property so
what if you didn't have a son what if
you had a daughter and you wanted to
leave your property to your daughter
there were sort of workarounds where you
would you know you would name an air
legally but that person agreed to you
know take care of the asset for your
let's say for your daughter and then
when your daughter had children that
those assets would pass down to to her
children and to bring the asset back
into your you know into your bloodline
so those are really some of the earliest
trusts but if you fast forward to you
know the UK
um you know during the the Dark Ages
during the Crusades uh people were very
concerned about protecting wealth
because you know they were going off to
war maybe they were going to come back
in 10 years maybe they weren't going to
come back at all and and so the modern
day trust structure was really
um invented during that that era and
it's still the number one way that
people protect the asset and we can
spend a lot of time on it and you know
we'll spend as much time as we have but
the very most simple notion of a trust
is that unlike a company or a
partnership or something that you own a
trust is not something you really own
it's its own juridical person right it's
separate and distinct from you so if if
I take my assets and I put them into a
trust structure and then somebody comes
and sues me well even if they're
successful in suing me they can't get
the asset because I don't own the Aspen
anymore and they don't have standing to
sue the trust because the trust is a
separate legal juridical person so that
in a nutshell is you know what makes
trust so effective if you've properly
created them properly transferred assets
into them and you know you can't do it
after the lawsuit has already been filed
that's we get a lot of calls like that
and you know we're not able to
necessarily help people because you get
into something called fraudulent
conveyances where you know somebody's
running around after they've been sued
trying to say all right what what can I
do to stop a plaintiff and at that point
it's it's very difficult you can
actually cross the line into
um you know the criminal lines of what
you're really allowed to do and what
you're not allowed to do but if you
you've set it up properly at the outset
transferred assets there properly
legally then that trust is a separate
person and and so if if a would-be
plaintiff comes after you uh and they
don't have an independent cause of
action against the trust which they
almost never would then
um you know the most they're going to
get is uh
um uh you know a a Judicial award
against you let's say against me uh but
I don't have any assets anymore because
I put them in a trust so so that's how
you haven't necessarily protected
yourself but you have protected the
assets by transferring them to you know
a third entity like a trust so as you
think about these trust structures how
much of it is legal liability protection
or mitigation versus maybe taxation
which seems to be another thing that
people very much focus on when it comes
to Estate Planning and a lot of this
asset protection
yeah that's a great question and and
that's a question that people always ask
you know in the first five ten minutes
of a of a phone conversation uh Trust on
the surface are tax neutral meaning they
don't they don't increase your taxes
they don't decrease your taxes at least
from an income tax perspective there are
some uh generational wealth and estate
benefits for example right now we have a
a lifetime exemption amount on what you
can leave to your children or
grandchildren that's about 13 million
dollars without Federal uh gift and
estate tax so if I create a trust today
for example and I put 13 million dollars
in that that trust and then over the
next you know 30 years of my life if if
God willing I should live so long that
13 million grows to 30 million or 50
million you know any kind of
appreciation takes place it's already
been transferred out of my estate so
it's never going to be subject to a
state tax so there are some there are
some tax benefits in that sense but from
an income tax perspective whether I earn
the money or the trust earns the money
you know the there's a capital gain it's
going to be taxed exactly the the same
there are things you can do for example
you know life insurance is one technique
uh there are some techniques with IRAs
and 401ks and uh star steps and kios
that you can move offshore to get the
same kind of legal tax deferral on the
asset but for the most part
um there's no real tax benefit what it
really is is it's a it opens up benefits
that have to do with estate planning you
have much more flexible estate planning
much more protection from creditors if
you're sued and and the big one in the
last 10 years honestly has been to open
up the world of investment I I know I
said a minute ago that asset protection
you know where the defense the
investment advisors they're the offense
but what most Americans don't realize is
that 75 percent of the world's
Investments are closed to them why why
is the World closed to Americans well
has to do with our laws it has to do
with the SEC you know claiming the
ability to regulate foreign companies if
they take on U.S investors so most of
the
um Investments around the world outside
the U.S are closed to Americans so but
with these types of structures a trust
for example I said it was a separate
legal juridical person it is and it
takes on the nationality of the
jurisdiction where it's established so
if I create a trust for you in in Belize
or the Cook Islands or you know in
Liechtenstein or someplace like that
then that's the nationality of that
trust now that trust can go make an
investment that you or I can't and and
really since the implementation of fatca
which came in which was passed in 2010
under President Obama went into full
force in 2014. we've seen door after
door after door shut to Americans when
they want to invest in almost anything
outside the country and these types of
offshore structures are really designed
to reopen those doors and I get more and
more people today they're not worried
about lawsuits they're not worried about
taxes you know they just want to be able
to invest their money the way they they
want to invest and you know getting some
Global diversification away from the
dollar is important
you mentioned a couple of jurisdictions
you mentioned Belize Lichtenstein and
some of the islands uh talk a little bit
about the various jurisdictions are
there pros and cons to each one is it a
80 90 of the value is derived just by
doing it offshore versus onshore how do
you think about jurisdiction when it
comes to some of these types of legal
entities
yeah that's a great question so you
start with the universe of things be
being either onshore or offshore right
so once you go offshore what you've
really done it from uh
um from a litigation perspective is
you've changed the Dynamics of where
future litigation would have to take
place so just the fact that you're
offshore anywhere is in itself a a an
advantage somebody's suing you the U.S
is the most pro-plaintiff jurisdiction
that exists the you know there's a new
lawsuit filed in the U.S every 17
seconds of every minute of every hour of
every day so and and we know that the
nuisance value of a lawsuit is is around
40 to 50 000 so you know it it sort of
turns into green mail in the U.S where
um law firms will actually require young
litigation Associates to file so many
lawsuits per day imagine that to keep
your job you know your job job is to go
file five lawsuits a day well that's the
that's sort of the universe that we live
in
um so now you move to the offshore world
where the laws are for the most part the
opposite they're very Pro defense
um it's you know you know many of these
jurisdictions don't allow contingency
fees for example
um there if you're going after let's say
a trust structure there has to be a
claim against the asset before it's uh
transferred into the trust structure so
if the claim arises after the trust
structure it's statutorily barred from
you bringing litigation at all and and
and so those are the reasons at the
macro level why you would consider
offshore onshore offshore you know it's
jurisdiction shopping you're getting
away from a very Pro plaintiff system
now once you've made the decision okay
I'm going to go offshore now you get
into the specifics of the jurisdictions
and I would divide the world there's a
lot of different
um
places in the world you know I think at
last count we'd worked in over 43
countries around the world but the big
groupings tend to be the the
um the English common law grouping so
that's that's where Belize uh the Cook
Islands uh Aruba Nevis you know you
could jump over to Great Britain the um
you know the Channel Islands Australia
New Zealand that's sort of one big
universe of English common law uh you
know a lot of people like those
jurisdictions because the uh the the the
judicial cases and interpretation are
very well you know the path has been
very well trodden
you can get a lot of examples in almost
any field in any case where and see
which cases the the judges were
supportive of the legal structures and
which cases they weren't and then you
can kind of engineer around that and
make sure that you stay in a very safe
area after the after the the sort of
British uh common law which most people
like because they're all English
speaking and the laws seem very familiar
to to us as American very familiar to
Canadians then the next school would be
the Germanic school so we're talking
about Germany Switzerland Austria
Liechtenstein you know you have about a
hundred million Germanic people in the
center of Europe uh the rules tend to be
very very precise less is open to court
jurisdiction with judges it's more laid
out and codified in in very very
detailed rules
um and a lot of people like that I'm my
family came from Germany
um I'm a German origin myself and
there's a certain comfort in knowing
that you know if the if the law says X
um and you do this that and the other
you know the law is the law and nobody's
ever going to be able to change it
once you get away from the the you know
the the British school being number one
the Germanic school being number two you
have a lot of little pockets you know
the French have their little
um uh their little you know ex-colonies
Martinique
um you know places like that where you
can where you can get better asset
protection where they generally in these
jurisdictions don't add any layer of tax
so you know you asked before about
attacks the the jurisdiction itself
doesn't Levy any tax but as an American
person you're subject to taxation on
your worldwide income so it really
doesn't matter whether you you know set
up a trust in Delaware or in uh you know
Nevis or in Liechtenstein the tax
consequences from the irs's perspective
are going to be the same so that's why
you know when we when we talk about
taxes if somebody calls me and they
think oh I'm gonna like quote unquote
hide my money offshore I'm not going to
pay any tax you know that's where you
invite them to you know contact someone
else because you know they they're going
to end up in an orange jumpsuit and you
don't really want that
um but when it comes to the the
jurisdictions
um being offshore is most important
anywhere and then after that you get
into the specifics of maybe where you
want to be where you want your money to
be how you want your money to be
invested
um things like the rule against
perpetuities how long do you want to
create a trust is it just for one
generation for your children or two
generations for your grandchildren or do
you want to create a dynasty trust to go
on for the next Thousand Years all of
those types of considerations would
impact the specific jurisdiction but you
know honestly any of the jurisdictions
would be far superior to keeping your
money in the U.S so what's fascinating
about this conversation uh is when I've
heard people talk about this in the past
uh one of the biggest complaints which
you mentioned is uh United States
citizens are taxed on their worldwide
income meaning that whether you made the
money in the US or anywhere else you're
paying taxes to Uncle Sam uh there's
proponents that argue that there's a
whole bunch of benefits and reasons why
that's appropriate there's a bunch of
critics who say that's not appropriate
and here's all the reasons why we
shouldn't that's the rules it is what it
is somebody can go debate that elsewhere
but what it then brings up is like well
maybe I shouldn't be a U.S citizen
anymore and when you talk to immigrants
usually they'll be like I work so hard
to get here I can't imagine a world
where I would renounce my U.S
citizenship but there's a lot of people
in the U.S who kind of were just born
into it right and frankly they may not
have the same appreciation for it or
they think that the economic gain would
be so great that they consider it but
there's this like exit tax uh and then
also there's the question of like well
where would they go and so maybe talk a
little bit from a taxation standpoint
being a U.S citizen if somebody did
renounce the citizenship and then what
exactly their other options would be and
kind of what that process looks like
great well you know you you asked a lot
of questions in that question well do do
my best you know let's let's start at
the end and work backwards
um before you can even contemplate
giving up U.S citizenship the law says
that you must have another citizenship
because you can't renounce your U.S
citizenship and thereby become a
stateless person so you know if you if
you start from okay if I'm if I would
ever give up my U.S citizenship I'd
better have a second citizenship now
most people view a second citizenship
the way they view you know life
insurance it's it's it's a planning tool
you know they're going to get a passport
somewhere they're going to stick it in
the safety deposit box they hope they
never need it but if they need it they
have it
um if you're really seriously
considering uh giving up your U.S
citizenship then you would want to think
long and hard about the kind of
citizenship that you would want
um the countries for example that that
offer what's called economic citizenship
where you're basically just writing a
check and buying a passport most of the
Caribbean islands for example have those
types of programs they the lowest ones
start at about a hundred thousand
dollars you write a check two to three
months later you know you're a citizen
you have your passport your certificate
of naturalization
um and there's nothing wrong with those
I have lots of clients that would would
have those types of passports but you
know the U.S passport is one of the best
passports in the world and so you would
be making a major trade down to replace
the U.S passport with a a an island
passport so most people will get those
types of passports maybe as an interim
measure while they work through a longer
process most other countries it takes
anywhere from you know three to six
years the average is about five years
where you make an investment you set up
residency and then over time you can
become a citizen there are a number of
programs in your Europe
um you know as well as some of the other
common law countries we talked about
Australia New Zealand they all have
their advantages disadvantages Canada
for example
you know Canada is an interesting
country for second citizenship because
under the North American Free Trade
Agreement NAFTA uh Canadians are the
only people in the world that are
guaranteed the legal right of access to
the United States anyone else you know
that that's it's uh executive orders
it's it's you know things that can be
easily Changed by law
European citizenship for example many
people seek to try to get uh citizenship
in countries like Malta that have a an
economic citizenship program Bulgaria
um either golden Visa programs and the
Southern Tier countries Portugal Spain
um Italy Greece and those programs can
lead to citizenship but again you know
even a European passport is really
sought after because it's generally just
as good as as a U.S passport but Canada
is the only one that that is guaranteed
by treaty under NAFTA that that
Canadians have the free right of access
so if you're going to give up your U.S
citizenship but you want to make sure
that you can always come back to the U.S
you know Canada is number one the the
European countries probably collectively
number two and you know then after that
it's um you know it's a diverse group of
countries mostly where you have to get
visas to come to the United States so
that's the that's the the backdrop um
for your question
um if you live outside the United States
but you don't ex-patriate you can't
qualify for something called the foreign
earned income exclusion and the foreign
earned income exclusion or FEI for short
allows you to exempt the first it's
about a hundred ten thousand dollars
this year the tax that's per person so
it would be double that per married
couple if you're living abroad you could
no you could be exam from taxes on that
amount so I'm seeing more and more
people want to take advantage of that
young people digital Nomads that want to
live abroad you know they're not really
thinking about expatriation they very
much like their US Passport they might
get a second residence or citizenship
over time but they want to take
advantage of the foreign earned income
exclusion
working back even more now let's talk
about a wealthy person that just says
Okay I I either quickly or slowly the
other way is what's called ancestral
citizenship so if it turns out your
parent or grandparent came from a lot of
countries you can go back and claim
citizenship rather than applying for
citizenship like economic citizenship or
going through residency the economic or
excuse me the ancestral citizenship is
basically saying look my father my
mother my grandparents they came from
wherever let's say Germany and I am
really German and I would like to that
to be recognized and that's a different
process but if you can qualify for
ancestral
um citizenship that's what a lot of
people are interested in doing the
number one countries that that honor
that going back multiple Generations the
UK Ireland Italy those are probably the
three most
um common so
anyway whichever of those ways you go
the the fast cheap the fast expensive
way the slow cheap way the ancestral way
those are all three ways to get your
your citizenship now you have it and now
you come to me and say Joel I'm thinking
about expatriating and giving up my U.S
citizenship what does that look like
from a tax perspective well there's
special forums that you have to fill out
one is uh with the IRS and you mentioned
the word X attacks
it's not technically an X attacks
um you know I think of exit taxes is
like for example the the Jews that were
leaving you know Russia during the Cold
War you know the the the Russian
government would say okay you know you
have assets and we're going to take you
know some big percentage of them if you
want to leave you have to Fork it over
or else you can't leave
um what the what the U.S taxes on
expatriation is they treat you as if you
sold all of your assets the day before
you expatriated and it's it's basically
a deemed capital gains tax and a gained
income tax so let's imagine that you
know I you know for your group let's say
I picked up a bunch of Bitcoin at the
beginning and now I'm sitting on you
know 300 million dollars of Bitcoin and
it was never taxed and now I want to
give up my U.S citizenship what I pay a
tax on that yes I would I would pay a
large capital gains tax that would be
you know 20 capital gain plus the Obama
health care tax 3.8 percent I would pay
23.8 percent tax on that number and then
you're gonna say well Joel that that is
a that is an exit tax then I would and I
would say I wouldn't argue with you I
would say that you're you're being
forced to pay the tax that you would
have to pay uh when you sell that asset
but it's not truly an exit tax because
let's imagine instead of having a couple
hundred million dollars of Bitcoin let's
say you had a couple hundred million
dollars of cash sitting in your bank
account and these were all after tax
dollars
um you could get on a plane tomorrow
expatriate fill out the paperwork
um and not be a U.S person anymore and
you wouldn't owe one cent of tax
um why because the the cash itself is
already after tax dollars there's no you
know inherent capital gain associated
with it so you know it's a it's it's way
more complicated than what I just
explained but you know I think your your
viewers get the they understand in a
nutshell you know if you have
appreciated stocks bonds mutual funds
currencies crypto whatever gold
um you're gonna pay a deemed capital
gains tax if everything you own is you
know like I have clients that bought
Bitcoin you know last year when it was
16 the thousand and now it's twenty
thousand so would they pay uh would they
pay a tax if they left no they wouldn't
owe any tax if anything they would maybe
be trying to recapture you know losses
so that that's the way that quote
unquote X attacks works right it's a
great question you know we we see about
the the official published numbers are
about ten thousand people per year are
expatriating
um and so you know there's what two
million illegal immigrants coming in the
US every year you know we're not going
to run out of people you know with that
formula but the 10 000 people that are
leaving are you know they're not only
wealthy people generally but they tend
to be entrepreneurs they tend to be job
creators
um so it's it's a concerning phenomenon
I mean if you go back 10 years it was in
the hundreds of people per year it was
600 800 it it ran up into the thousands
and now you know we're over ten thousand
and that's only the numbers that the the
government then you know publishes and
acknowledges I I actually suspect that
the numbers are a good bit higher yeah
what's fascinating about what you're
talking about is basically they're using
this taxation as a way to disincentivize
people from trying to avoid the capital
gains right and I always think of
Taxation as uh there's incentives and
there's kind of like the stick as well
and this feels like uh the the thick
component of Taxation where they say
look if you have appreciated assets and
then you try to leave uh we're not going
to let you do that without paying the
tax uh but I did not know the point
about if you just have a bunch of cash
laying around uh then obviously that's
uh post-taxology so it's interesting
kind of the the intricacies if uh if you
will
yeah I know it's it's very interesting
and and some clients are very pleasantly
surprised when they come and they
thought they were going to have to write
a multi-million dollar check and they
find out they owe nothing uh but the
opposite is also true where people have
said well I'd like to expatri trade but
honestly it's not worth
um you know paying uh an immediate
capital gain stocks of 30 40 50 million
dollars and then they it influences as
you said it's it's the it's the stick
that kind of keeps them in line yeah it
uh I'm not planning on that I've even
got the flag behind me so uh I'll I'll
leave it to the experts to figure that
one out uh in terms of uh earlier you
mentioned a school teacher or a
secretary right and you're just picking
two occupations but people who uh
they're not multi-millionaires right and
most people would think oh asset
protection isn't for me what do you see
with um what I would call your average
uh kind of Citizen right what are they
doing when it comes to asset protection
uh is it simply just a trust structure
or are there other things that may be
worth the audience understanding that
you know kind of the everyday person is
also doing this not just the ultra
wealthy
yeah that's a that's a very good
question I I would say that first and
foremost a lot of people that have
modest wealth you know a few hundred
thousand dollars let's say uh they might
not even want to create a structure
because you know even if the structure
costs ten or twenty thousand dollars
it's a disproportionately large amount
based on the wealth they have so a lot
of times they they'll use the asset mix
as the as the form of protection maybe
the titling how you title something
um if you're really worried about being
sued but starting with the asset mix
they tend to want to move away from cash
um traditional stocks and bonds and
mutual funds so they you know I'm seeing
historically the number one investment
from an asset protection perspective is
gold why I mean you know gold pretty
much always holds its value
um you know you can throw it in your
suitcase and get on a plane and leave if
you to if you need to leave some people
have a lot of gold maybe store it in a
in a vault somewhere like Switzerland uh
Switzerland uh houses two-thirds of all
the world's private gold reserves so you
know and it's it's very common to have
safe deposit box type you know
structures in uh in a bank in
Switzerland where you have a little
drawer with your you have the lock and
you know your gold sitting in a drawer
somewhere that's a simple example
um you know cryptocurrency and Bitcoin
has certainly moved into that space as
well because you know Bitcoin in some
ways functions much like gold because
it's not anything that a government can
produce uh they can't just push a button
and and and uh inflate away the value
and and I think that's what you know
more and more people view that as asset
protection these days they're saying I I
work my whole life you know for my
little nest egg and you know I don't
want to find out well you know that the
dollar all of a sudden has become worth
if not worth less worthless
um you know I mean the the famous French
philosopher Voltaire 200 years ago said
that every paper currency will
eventually reach its intrinsic value
then that value zero it's just how long
does it take to get there well if and by
the way I'm not I'm not necessarily a
gold bug but I think gold we can we can
all agree that something governments
can't you know flip a switch and easily
produce so you know it's been a store of
value for 5 000 years if you go back a
hundred years ago
um one ounce of gold would get cost
twenty dollars and with that one ounce
of gold you could get a finely tailored
Man's suit and you fast forward to today
you know an ounce of gold is eighteen
hundred dollars and with eighteen
hundred dollars you can go get a finely
made Man suit so as a as a purchasing
power it's gold state same as the
Dollar's gone down so gold Bitcoin real
estate is another asset class that I see
people that are worried about uh losing
the purchasing power of their currency
tend to put their money in when it comes
to structures you know you can have
simple structures you can have a little
company maybe where the shares transfer
over to your children family limited
Partnerships
um sometimes people will simply buy an
asset whether it's you know gold or real
estate and put it in their children's
name that's a quick way to
you know get it out of your own name if
you're worried about you know future
litigation again if you're in the middle
of litigation and you do that probably
some clever plaintiff's attorney is
going to track you down and and uh
reverse the the transaction but you know
if you do it today and something happens
five or ten years from now
um they're not going to be able to go
after that asset so so that those are
ways that people can do things without
setting up complex structures once you
move from the couple hundred thousand to
the couple million that's where really
it makes more sense you know be you you
want to preserve and protect the asset
for yourself first of all you want to be
able to maybe invest it the way you want
it to be invested
um but then eventually you want that
estate planning component which is what
happens to the money at my death and
trusts are a great way to do that as
well they're private you know it's it's
not going to go through probate where
you know people are going to see what
you have
um because again the trust is a separate
legal juridical person so when you die
your trust doesn't die you know it it
the if you were the primary beneficiary
of that trust you know you you kind of
get swapped out for whoever's next in
line maybe it's your spouse your
children your grandchildren whomever the
beneficiaries change but the legal
entity known as the trust that has not
changed and and that's why people like
it from that perspective as well it's
private and it's a way to transition
wealth from a one generation to the next
yeah it's fascinating uh one of the
things that people love hearing are wild
Tax Strategies and uh across very many
you know I've done 1100 1200 of these
shows uh and had all kinds of people on
and learned a ton from them uh but we've
heard some crazy ones uh there there's
like simple Crazy Ones like hey if you
have a vehicle that's more than I think
six thousand pounds or whatever you can
write it off and you know that's
available to anyone and everyone uh all
the way to literally if you buy a house
in cash and then you take out a mortgage
against it and then invest that money
rather than use it for more mortgage
payments you can then go ahead and all
of your mortgage payments are write-offs
on your taxes because it's an investment
loan and the whole thing right so
there's literally the entire uh Gambit
what's the craziest thing you've seen
someone do from a tax mitigation
standpoint
well you know I think sometimes people
spend more time and energy
and money trying to save taxes my focus
with my clients is always first and
foremost you know how do we make money
how are you holding your assets
um how are you protecting them uh but
yeah I I do see uh crazy things the tax
shelters and you know the the IRS has
really tried to crack down on them and
even made the professionals the lawyers
and the accountants who who pitch them
and promote them can be
um personally liable for uh penalties so
I'm I'm really a pretty conservative guy
I know sometimes people think well geez
you're in the offshore space but there
are plenty of things that you can do in
the offshore space that are perfectly
legal taking advantage of you know uh
you know like some of the Clauses that
you're talking about
um you know for example there's nothing
that says you can't move your IRA
offshore and
um you know you're not inventing a new
wheel uh to say that an IRA is tax
deferred no it's it is tax deferred
right I don't have to convince you of
that you already know that but a lot of
people don't know that they can take
their existing IRA and move it offshore
and then invest in it uh in a offshore
they don't have to be invested in
dollars they could be invested in
traditional Investments or they could be
invested in non-traditional Investments
um or you know things like life
insurance again most people think okay I
you know I can deal with you know Snoopy
or the you know New York Life or one of
those uh companies but you don't have to
there's there's there's nothing that
says you can't buy Life Insurance in a
foreign country even though you're an
American and you live in the U.S and and
all of a sudden the the cash value of
that policy can be invested in you know
a lot of different things because you
don't have the state
um you know I live in Pennsylvania
you know Maryland or Virginia or
whatever wherever you're from you know
it's the states that control what can be
in an insurance policy so when you take
that life insurance policy offshore you
get rid of the States you still have to
abide by all the federal rules
concerning insurance but there are no
State rules and what that means is you
can invest in almost anything you want
so those are the things that that people
tried to do I don't view them as really
wacky they're they're actually quite
conservative they're taking advantage of
the rules that are already in existence
the the thing that concerns me where
where you know is people still have
these outdated views that well if I put
money offshore nobody's gonna know about
it or if I put money offshore I I don't
have to pay tax until I bring the money
back to the States those are all wrong
those are all misnomers
um some of those principles like you
only pay tax when you bring the money
back to the States you know that used to
be in the tax code but that was changed
under Ronald Reagan in like 1984. so you
know that hasn't been the norm in you
know 40 years so 30 years
um you know so part of my job is just
educating people and I say look if if we
can help you we're we're very happy to
do that if you want to do something
that's goes across the line you know if
it's if it's illegal immoral unethical
um you'll have to do it on your own
because it's not you know it's not
something again I've been in this
business 32 years I sleep very well at
night I I don't plan to ever wear an
orange jumpsuit with a serial number
across the back and you know people that
get too aggressive in this space they do
risk that you know I I remember reading
about Leona Helmsley and she made the
comment about only little people pay
taxes and you know next thing you know
she was uh you know she spent the latter
years of her life in a federal
penitentiary so you know I want to help
clients do things correctly legally uh
take advantage of the the rules that are
already there I'm not you know coming up
with something new and wacky that that I
just thought up or tried to string
things together in a in a in a new way
um to to you know I get people that even
come to me and say look the U.S tax code
is illegal it's it's unconstitutional
and I say sure if you want to fight that
fight go ahead but you know I'm my
life's too short for you know taking on
that that battle there are legitimate
um arguments as to the the you know the
um the the Constitutional Amendment that
authorized uh the IRS and the um and
federal taxation was in fact
um incorrect but again I I'm not
prepared to go up against you know one
of the largest bureaucracies in the
world um trying to fight that and you're
almost certainly going to lose so um I
think Life's too short for that I I tend
to agree uh the last thing I want to
talk about is uh Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies a lot of people in the
audience uh either hold them or
interested in them learning about them
uh you've mentioned a couple of times
that many of your clients uh or at least
now becoming interested have become
interested uh what are you seeing there
is there anything specifically at the
kind of intersection of crypto and
whether it's estate planning tax
planning anything like that
well yeah I I've seen a lot of elements
in the last particularly two or three
years you know I know crypto's been
around longer than that but the people
that had crypto five and ten years ago
they weren't necessarily wealthy and the
banks didn't really care about them
um now all of a sudden you know you have
this whole new
um class of people that are you know
multi-millionaires and even billionaires
and uh I think a lot of the traditional
financial institutions Banks trust
companies insurance companies they're
they're all starting to take notice
um so you have some of the early movers
in the space
um you know Dell tech in in the Bahamas
you have Bank Frick in in Liechtenstein
that really led the way in what they
called crossover Finance
um the these were some of the banks that
were really out there now you know even
some of the I you read almost every day
in the news about you know the
traditional the Merrell lynches or the
bank Americas and and and they're trying
to figure out ways to cater to uh the
crypto Community uh We've we've seen uh
trust companies come up with new ways to
be able to properly hold uh crypto that
that's something they never had to do
they you know they work with companies
like fire blocks and you know other
companies that can provide the the kind
of security that that clients want you
know I mean somebody's not going to walk
in off the street and say you know
here's uh here's a flash drive with uh
you know two thousand three thousand
four thousand Bitcoin and you know I'm
just gonna Fork it over to wherever you
know is nice to me they want proof that
the that the security you know is at the
very highest level and and I think that
as we go forward the next three four
five years as Bitcoin makes another you
know Bull Run and becomes a lot more
valuable again uh you know you'll have
the financial institutions that figure
out how to keep up and and cater and
serve uh the crypto community and and
those who don't and the ones who don't
you know I think a lot of them will will
go out of business or or or become sort
of the the second tier you know probably
local Community Banks maybe won't but
the big banks that that want to cater to
wealthy people they're they're basically
being forced to learn quickly hire
people from those sectors to come in and
help them organize their Affairs and as
you said there's there's sort of two
groups you've got wealthy people from
some other industry they made their
money in real estate or you know their
their business or whatever and now they
want to sort of dabble in the in the
crypto space they're sort of the late
comers they've come along in the last
one or two or three years but then the
other group are the people that were the
the early adopters you know they were
they were getting you know Bitcoin when
it was under ten dollars you know
ethereum it you know pennies and and
those people are you know that's a very
very interesting crowd you know a lot of
them never thought that they were
wealthy they still don't think of
themselves as wealthy
um you know and they are just slowly
coming out of the woodwork and we we
talk to those folks every day and that's
what they want to know they want to know
okay if I engage in traditional asset
protection estate planning you know can
the structures keep up the legal
structures first and foremost but then
the the financial institutions you know
how can I be certain how can I sleep at
night knowing that you know my my
bitcoin's safe and and a lot of them
come from the crowd where you know it's
it's sitting on a flash drive somewhere
and they're the only ones that know
about it but we've all read about the
stories of you know the guy who threw
away his computer in New York and he had
100 million dollars of a Bitcoin on it
so so that's a bit of a wake-up call as
well and you know they they do want
traditional asset protection estate
planning you know if they get hit by a
bus tomorrow and die they want to make
sure that their kids and you know their
family can and Charities whomever can
access their their wealth so it's a
balancing act we have to
um you know convince folks that the the
the right kind of systems and structures
are in place it is new these you know
like I said if I if I I've been doing
this 32 years but in the crypto space
only probably less than five so all of
the banks and Trust companies they're
all scurrying around some faster than
others to to really put the the best
system structures protocols in place to
serve the crypto community and and you
know I think crypto sitting right now
about two two trillion all of the crypto
industry but you know as as Bitcoin as
the leader and ethereum takes off again
you know that number is only going to
increase so I think more and more
financial institutions will be wanting
to cater to to that clientele and uh
it's really it's really pretty exciting
I mean you know I'm sort of in the
Twilight of My Career but you know it's
it's the old dogs learning new tricks
and try to adapt things that I've been
working with you know my whole career to
the the crypto community and it's it's
been you know very exciting I think that
you're doing a fantastic job and what's
unique about this is uh while you think
that you're learning about all the new
stuff I think there's a lot of people
from this new digital world they're
learning from people who have been doing
uh quite well and understanding uh kind
of the Legacy infrastructure and and
different rules and regulations and
entities and things like that so I
really appreciate you taking so much of
your time today to uh to help people
kind of get a quick taste and and really
just the high level concepts of asset
protection uh if there are people who
want to learn more or need help with
certain things where can we send people
to reach you on the internet is there an
email Twitter where would you like us to
send them well sure I mean I'm on there
naglelaw.com
um [ __ ] law at
protonmail.com uh you can call my office
area code
412-749-0500 you know and I'm pretty
pretty easy to find if if you Google me
Joel Nagel awesome I don't think
anyone's ever given out a phone number
before so we're gonna see how that goes
uh hopefully everyone is nice and they
don't just start calling non-stop asking
hey how do I get rich I I might I might
get an earful from my secretary for
giving out that number
hopefully it's all right yeah just go to
Twitter don't go to the phone number
that's all good all right Joel listen
thank you so much for uh for doing this
uh every time that you and I talk I
learned a ton and uh it is uh it's a
topic that I hear more and more from
people so I appreciate you taking the
time to come on and help everyone learn
a little bit and uh anyone who wants to
reach out reach out to Joel and we'll go
from there but uh thanks so much and
we'll definitely do this again in the
future
thanks again I really appreciate it was
fun